c'est une certaine curiosité pour
l'autre vieille question qui nous
poursuit depuis des millénaires
donc si on me propose de rencontrer un
autre aussi extraordinaire qu'un
extraterrestre
moi je dit oui tout de suite invoquons
feront un réalisateur me l'avait proposé
il ya quelques années dans une fiction
avec entrée avant avoir trois heures de
conversation avec un visiteurs
extraterrestres
tout ça a été et bien non seulement de
la fiction mais l'exercice est toujours
intéressant d'être confronté à quelque
chose que vous ne connaissez pas donc
oui cela m'intéresse personnellement
maintenant il ya effectivement le
contexte général et qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour l'humanité dans son
intégrité j'allais dire même
et puis cette planète terre là les
auteurs de science fiction
imaginez quand même beaucoup de
scénarios dont une partie n'est quand
même pas tout à fait à notre avantage
donc là effectivement on pourrait avoir
peur quand vous voyez le petit film
qu'on a vu au tout début celui qui a été
donc authentifié par le pentagone
filmées par un chasseur
voilà celui qui a fait la couverture de
der spiegel vous vous voyez quoi vous
quand vous regardez ça voilà un point
qui se baladent
mais voyez j'ai essayé de faire
l'exercice en temps mais qu'est ce qu'on
voit exactement parce que je suis censé
être dans un avion avec un viseur et
comment comment il arrive à suivre
moi sa place à dépasse ma capacité de
d'appréhension la chose c'est pour ça
que je suis un bon ok ça existe mais
j'ai pas de repères c'est pas que vous
savez dans la rue vous vous promenez
vous voyez des choses que je ne vois pas
et inversement parce que nous ne sommes
pas câblé de la même manière il faut
apprendre
vous savez bien si vous connaissez une
région vous allez faire découvrir des
choses que les autres ne voient pas
c'est la même chose là c'est un monde
qui moi mais totalement inconnu vous
pouvez montrer tout ce que vous voulez
ok et là comment il fait pour suivre
regardez rien ne bouge là c'est le sol
qui bouge ça veut dire que lui avec son
avion il arrive je comprends pas donc je
suis désorientés donc j'ai besoin d'être
initié en quelque sorte peut-être qu'un
pilote pour m'initier
[Musique]